to have to go and resume I got something
exciting to show you breath today I got
my hands on an oculus rift these are for
those who don't know a virtual reality I
guess console you can call it it is
really cool I feel so like ha I tried
other virtual reality devices but like
nothing compares to this it really feels
like you're in the game so we're gonna
play a game that the developers were
cool enough to send me I'm the first one
to do a video on this game
with the oculus it's gonna be fun
alright it is the weirdest [ __ ] ever
once you go in it's like he's stepping
in and tired in your world so here we go
oh man this game it works really well
with the oculus okay you'll see the game
of wow this is so [ __ ] cool holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
let's play this one I don't want to jump
alright press
Yolo it's like I'm on [ __ ] drugs
wearing a gas mask or some [ __ ] like
that
nothing I would know what that is like
there we go I can do it one ran [ __ ]
a lot of commentate on then like I'm
falling what the [ __ ] how does your time
yeah but I know it yeah the freakiest
[ __ ] is looking behind you he's here
like what the [ __ ] that is not supposed
to be that half the fun is just [ __ ]
looking around where's my mouse that's
my microphone okay let's play whoa I can
head back in the game
I don't know what this day but it's just
like so [ __ ] cool think of all the
porn this changes everything
Oh what are your doing go knock the post
of the years what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh here we go here we go
tick boy are you [ __ ] kidding me
wow I'm so lame I [ __ ] love this so
far that was still drinks are on me
thanks on me breath that is so cool I
pressed I got up to end it here that was
a lot of fun
let me both know what else you wanted me
to play I think there's a couple horror
games I think that'd be pretty
interesting
maybe I can be shown watching hit
subscribe to come abroad today and I'll
see in the next one say awesome brothers
love you
[Music]
right there